[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal local
voici les titres de ce mercredi 26 avril
du ceap et au bac +5 l'apprentissage à
l'honneur à la maison de l'étudiant
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines en partenariat avec l'ue vs qu
organisé aujourd'hui un salon dédié à
l'apprentissage 200 personnes ont pu
découvrir une vingtaine de stands et
autant de métiers voisins le bretonneux
dans l'actualité également la majorité
municipale demande la révision de la loi
sru celle ci prévoit un taux de
logements sociaux de 25 % pour les
communes voisins souhaitent que ce taux
soit repensé à l'échelle intercommunale
et puis le portrait d'une jeune
pâtissière dans ce journal mais li na da
silva est étudiante au lycée hôtelier de
guyancourt allé récemment arrivé
deuxième au championnat régional de
dessert vous découvrirez sa passion
qu'elle construit en partie aux côtés de
son grand père non n'ouvre ce journal
sur des informations révélées par le
journal le parisien une opération
antiterroriste a eu lieu ce matin à
trappes quatre personnes ont été
interpellées et placées en garde à vue
des arrestations dans le cadre d'une
enquête préliminaire ouverte en février
par le parquet antiterroriste de paris
selon des informations communiquées à la
fp aussi ces quatre personnes
cherchaient à se procurer des armes mais
aucun passage à l'acte imminent n'était
prévu sans transition je vous le disais
en titre la première édition des
rencontres de l'apprentissage était
organisée aujourd'hui à la maison de
l'étudiant à guyancourt objectif
renseigner les étudiants alors que
l'apprentissage permis à cette jeune sur
dix de trouver un emploi pour l'occasion
des apprentis sont venus raconter leur
expérience
un reportage de
mais qu'allait demi d'euros barbara 22
ans est apprenti depuis septembre
dernier veut partager son expérience
actuellement en formation dans une
entreprise de sidérurgie cette ville
prose yen s'est inscrite pour les
rencontres de l'apprentissage à la
maison de l'étudiant de mu en cours
pendant la journée l'étudiante a
présenté son parcours
la question qui vont me revenir ça va
être surtout sur comment se passe la
partie sage si au sein de mon entreprise
ça se passe bien
l'intégration des apprentis au sein des
services
ce que l'intégration des acomptes y est
très important c'est souvent ce qu'on
voit de plus en arrivant comme barbara
ils sont des dizaines d'apprentis et
s'être déplacé ce mercredi 26 avril pour
cette première édition
mon souhait c'est ça c'est vraiment que
des apprentis puissent témoigner
expliquer quelle est leur quotidien pour
donner envie à d'autres jeunes
effectivement de les rejoindre et de
devenir apprenti je suis rémunéré je
suis prise au sérieux dans l'entreprise
il est plus dans la même posture qu'un
élève le classique quoi il est devenu
vraiment salariés donc c'est vrai que
c'est autrement plus importants plus
plus plus parlant les apprentis
accompagné des responsables ont présenté
cette occasion les métiers accessibles à
tous les niveaux de formation du ca paix
à bac + 5
sur une vingtaine de stands un vrai plus
pour les 200 étudiants présents je
trouve ça toujours enrichissant
d'apprendre ce que les autres peuvent
faire et leur façon de voir les choses
donner des conseils
oui oui un petit peu mais après c'est
plutôt des échanges de points de vue en
tout cas vu le succès rencontré cette
année une deuxième édition devrait être
programmé d'après les chiffres de
l'éducation nationale cdn sur dix
trouvent à l'emploi la sortie de
l'apprentissage dans le reste de
l'actualité locale la bonne santé du
cinéma franciliens selon des chiffres
publiés hier par le groupe audiens et la
commission du film en ile de france le
secteur connaît une croissance
significatif depuis deux ans en 2016 le
nombre d'entreprises travaillant dans le
domaine a augmenté de 4% le cinéma made
in ile de france est notamment portée
par les hausses d'investissement + 28 %
et parmi ceux-ci vous le voyez à l'écran
on retrouve la série versailles tourné
en partie dans les décors du château à
voisins le bretonneux maintenant la
majorité municipale lance l'offensive
contre la loi sru avec un vote hier en
conseil pour demander sa révision cette
loi impose à de nombreuses communes
d'ile-de-france un seuil minimal de 25 %
de logements sociaux pour 2025
un taux que voisins aura du mal à
respecter puisqu'il est actuellement de
16 % la mère souhaite donc qu'il soit
repensé au niveau intercommunal
écoutez on nous montre un petit peu du
doigt moi j'ai absolument pas autant je
veux dire on construit au construit pas
mal de programmes à chaque fois il ya un
pourcentage de logement social mais la
difficulté pour voisin qui n'a presque
plus de foncier
ce serait que pour rattraper c'est 25 %
en 2025 ça veut dire qu'un programme
comme la remise la zac de la remise où
il ya 500 logements de prévu faudrait
que je fasse 90% logements sociaux et
puis un autre terrain qui s'appelle la
manivelle où il ya 95 à 100 logements de
prévu faudrait que j'en fasse 80% ou 90%
à voisins le bretonneux toujours la
ville organisé avec le centre alfred de
vigny la 11e
édition de son marché des terroirs vins
et gastronomie il y a quelques jours
l'occasion pour les habitants de
découvrir ou redécouvrir des produits
typiques venus de toute la france cette
année 25 exposants étaient présents
le but est de créer du lien social en
fait sur ce quartier
voilà et parterres participer aussi la
gastronomie et les terroirs
c'est aussi pour faire écho à nos
vacances puisqu'on va tous déguster sur
certains terroirs des saveurs et quand
on revient et on a la joie ici au marché
des terroirs de retrouver un petit peu
c'est ses saveurs comme la bretagne
comme la corse comme la provence voilà
on retrouve aussi les antilles la guyane
l'espagne le nigga et cetera tout ça
fait écho à notre madeleine de proust
[Musique]
notre portrait de la semaine est
consacrée à la cuisine à la cuisine et
plus précisément à la pâtisserie avis
aux gourmands
mélina da silva est étudiante au lycée
hôtelier de guyancourt elle a 20 ans et
en janvier elle est arrivée deuxième de
sa catégorie au championnat ile de
france du dessert camille lambert a
rencontré cette jeune passionnée
portrait
en pâtisserie comme en art il faut faire
preuve de créativité et pour réaliser sa
sculpture mais li na l'a bien compris
une oeuvre constituée de 50 kg de
chocolat ont fait une structure en
chocolat pour les portes ouvertes à
l'inauguration du nouveau lycée car il a
été fait récemment
et donc on a choisi de travailler sur la
musique et la nature donc on a mélangé
un arbre avec une guitare on l'a
dessinée et après
on a coulé du chocolat pour faire la
base de structures et on l'a collé en
polystyrène qu'on a pas
avec du chocolat une pièce qui ne sera
pas déguster mais exposer un défi pour
cette jeune pâtissière qui a déjà
l'habitude de se surpasser
mélina participer au championnat ile de
france du dessert
elle est arrivée deuxième de la
catégorie junior c'était d entraînement
très intense des gens très longue
donc on est quand même contents de la
position qu'on a eu sinon c'était une
bonne expérience dans l'ensemble ça
apprend aussi à avoir d'autres choses
parce qu'on a pu voir aussi les
professionnels travailler c'est un
excellent résultat excellent résultat je
suis très très content et s'est investi
à fond voilà prêt à lâcher donc c'est
très très bien a sorti un dessert propre
dans les temps ce n'est pas investi
intéressés et motivés
une motivation qui lui a servi pour
terminer sa création après plusieurs
mois de travail résultats dévoilés lors
des journées portes ouvertes de
l'établissement l'a collé quelques
éléments comme des feuilles quelques
fleurs pour pour égayer le tout est
ramené un peu de brillance encore
quelques détails à peaufiner mais les
visiteurs sont déjà conquis c'est un
beau travail et puis justement
s'interroger sur la technique qui avait
derrière parce que ça représente ada
parce que la jeune fille mais expliqué
50 kg de chocolat sa passion mélina m la
partager c'est avec son grand père
qu'elle réalise souvent des desserts
pour la famille aujourd'hui paris brest
revisité qu'est ce que tu fais un très
bon ça se faire par la tienne j'aime
bien tout ce qui est sucré un peu
gourmand et puis donc
sotoba de médina qui était à mes côtés
m'apporte beaucoup d'information
technique pour la réalisation différents
mais cette recette de philippe conticini
possède un coeur coulant au praliné
un bon moyen pour s'entraîner même après
six ans passés au lycée hôtelier
après sa scolarité mélina aimerait
intégrer un grand restaurant il ya plus
de travail dans l'assiette plus de
finition et puis y'a il ya les petits
les petits coups de feu en cuisine
du coup ça de plus de plus d'adrénaline
donc je pense que ça sera plus ce milieu
là un milieu qu'elle se dit prête à
rejoindre ne manque plus qu'à passer son
diplôme à la fin de l'année à montigny
le bretonneux la 14e édition des
prairiales était organisé ce week end à
la ferme du manet une cinquantaine
d'exposants ont participé à cette grande
fête des fleurs et des jardins comme à
son habitude l'intégralité des dons
récoltés ont été reversés au profit de
la lutte contre la cécité la cécité
excusez moi écouter sur ce sujet l'un
des responsables de l'événement
les gens viennent toujours acheter
quelque chose on a qu'à voir le nombre
de deux personnes qui ressorte avec un
sac à la sortie il y à trois personnes
sur quatre ou quatre personnes sur cinq
qui ressorte avec quelque chose par
contre si il découvre une petite
nouveauté ou quelque chose qui attire
l'oeil
effectivement ils sont tout à fait prêts
à prendre des conseils on referme ce
journal avec une histoire touchante
celle d'un couple qui s'est rencontré
dans les années 50 et qui ne sait plus à
qui tu es depuis jacqueline et lucien
raciborski maurepas siens viennent de
célébrer leurs noces de diamant soit 1
60 ans de mariage pour notre série de
reportages dédiés justement au mariage
nous leur avons demandé leur recette du
bonheur à camille lambert
il évoquera chose a commenté la thur
c'est le plus heureux de 60 ans c'est
par cette photo d'aujourd'hui
jacqueline et lucien se sont rencontrés
en 1951
mais au début ce n'était pas forcément
gagné c'est un petit bal de quartier
rené y rallier à paris dans le 3e
arrondissement
et puis nos conseils pour la soirée de
sable sont sans arrêt et nous très bien
soir je la raconte pas il habitait rue
du temps donc c'était juste à côté se
mouler et moi bien élevé j'ai voulu lui
faire un bisou ben bon bisous c'est
voler
elle a pas voulu j'allais au bal pas
pour justement pas pour chercher forte
comme on dit j'y allais vraiment parce
que ça ne l'a pas trouvé persévérant
lucien tente à nouveau la semaine
suivante
et c'est le début d'une longue relation
ils se marient à paris le 16 mars 1957
on impose d'aller couper ce que je vous
dis là elle se rappelle de la nuit de
noces à madina gérer en plus de leur vie
intime leur vie professionnelle se
fait-elle aussi main dans la main ils
exercent ensemble la profession de
charcutier leur secret est la seule 7 cm
avec l'âge ça change des sentiments ils
sont toujours amoureusement si vous
voulez mais le plus beau truc c'est de
ne pas pouvoir se passer l'un de l'autre
pour célébrer leur union le couple a
fêté en mars ses noces de diamant en
mairie de maurepas une cérémonie
émouvante
entourés de leurs enfants et même
arrière petits enfants
jacqueline et lucien habite la ville
depuis 1978
le maire leur a écrit un poème 60 ans
main dans la main amoureux comme les
bonheurs
quotidien chasse ne dit rien
voyez c'était belle image ses 60 ans en
arrière et voyez comme elle me regarde
je peux encore la regarder comme ça où
il est pas des yeux
mais je t'aime mon coeur allez c'est
vrai à 84 ans jacqueline et lucien
poursuivre leur route à 2 jusqu'à ce que
la mort les sépare
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le journal merci
de nous avoir suivi tous nos reportages
sont à retrouver en replay sur tv fil 78
points comme ou l'application tv fil 78
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]